yeah you've talked extensively um you
know about wanting a bunch of kids and
getting married and all that sort of
stuff and you know having a family um
have you set like put together a set of
guidelines rules or anything like that
somebody asked me um you know when I
posted on Twitter to ask him about how
start in the F uh he talks positively
about his plans to date marry have many
children yet hasn't started it's getting
older how's it start going so maybe to
sort of like elaborate on the plans for
that and you know what the strategy
happens to be I saw the other day you
posted uh you know for the first time
ever a picture of you and your a girl
yeah yeah well this is the this is the
funny thing with social media right
because people have all their
assumptions right I'm sure you know
there's people who think you you're
accuse you of I don't know be being an
incel or hating women or being this or
that because why doesn't Rich post a
picture of his girlfriend ugly or
something like that it's like no because
you're weird and that's why I don't need
to share it exactly right people people
have private lives yeah and I have many
reasons for not wanting to you know
share every imate detail with random
people on the internet to what are you
willing to share today yeah um so yeah I
have a wonderful girlfriend um we've
been together for six months now we are
very much aligned in terms of values in
terms of vision in terms of what we want
for the future or we get on incredibly
well we massively love each other we
trust each other and uh yeah we we would
like
to we would like to get married and have
a lot of babies together and you know
create create that family we have that
same vision so that's where that's where
I am personally MH um but like I say at
the same time I think um another thing
that can happen perhaps on the Internet
is people think
that people kind of can kind of ignore
the wider world and things happening
with other people and wider and other
culture because because they're okay
right it's the kind of the I'm all right
jack mentality right so maybe you're
well off and your business is doing well
and you've got money and whatever so ah
inflation who cares right it it doesn't
matter right it doesn't it doesn't
affect me I'm doing okay I can recognize
like I'm I'm I'm in a good position in a
lot of ways right but I can very clearly
see the struggles and problems and
challenges that a lot of men and a lot
of women are having out there right so I
think another thing that can can get
mixed up is when you are someone who
talks about these things people can be
very solipsistic and they they project
that either they internalize it and
personalize it for themselves or they
put it on to you right and this is what
happened this this is the reason why I
even posted that photo because I can be
talking about the issues that people are
having in the dating market and the
challenges that people don't understand
and I can be talking about you know my
thoughts on marriage or my thoughts on
divorce and all what whatever it is and
then people have the Assumption Oh
either oh well I think the person I was
responding to was saying something about
like how like I couldn't how you know I
I wouldn't be able to get a girlfriend
and like I probably can't get a second
day and I'm like look I'm not GNA like
Flex on you but I'm not I'm not strugg I
I haven't been struggling for for women
for most of my life like I'm not I'm not
here bragging and boasting yeah look at
all the chicks I'm getting whatever but
like that's for me personally that's not
a I'm okay right I'm in good shape but I
can still see that obesity is a problem
and something that a lot of people
struggle with it doesn't mean that I'm
struggling with obesity or I have a 40%
chance of becoming obese or whatever it
is um and as social commentators which
is something that we both do we just
talk about what we're seeing around us
we talk about things that people are
going through we can pull up statistics
and say okay what's going on here what's
causing this what are things that we can
do how can we give people better tools
how can we give people a better mindset
so that we can actually shift things in
a better Direction that's all that I'm
trying to do um I think that it's
incredibly important that the family is
so important Parenthood is important
like bringing up the Next Generation men
and women actually being able to get
along and couple up with each other and
create families that's the foundation of
a society that's why these conversations
are important um and I don't think that
the solution is okay cross your fingers
and touch wood and just jump into this
thing completely blindly and hope that
it all works out and you have no tools
and you're just unarmed I don't think
that's I don't think that's a great
strategy I also don't think a great
strategy is just okay take take no risk
at all right just stay away from the
opposite sex right because feminists do
the same thing as well right you've got
these feminists who literally will yeah
encourage women not right like stay stay
away from men their tox needs a man like
a fish needs a bicycle all you need is
your career your cats and your vibrator
right ex exactly right but there's also
a menist a menist version of this which
sort of flips around the other way women
are all evil it's not worth your time
exactly right there there's not much
Nuance there the truth is yes there are
there are evil men out there and there
are evil women out there I think as a
society in the west people feel a lot
more comfortable talking about the sins
of men than they feel comfortable
talking about the sins of women and I
think it's good that that is starting to
be balanced a bit more but I also don't
want it to overcorrect the other way so
that we go from you know 10 years ago
hasag uh hashtag you know men are trash
to hashtag in224 women are trash right
because no some people some people suck
there are some people who are absolutely
undatable absolutely unmarriageable
people who you really should not
reproduce with um but that is not unique
to either gender and ultimately you only
need to find that one person so it might
be the case that yeah okay I can
recognize the fact that yeah dating
marriage finding a decent woman all
these things are harder now than they
have been at certain times in the past
from what I understand from women they
feel the same same way right the there
are not as many eligible bachelors now
as there were let's say 30 or 40 years
ago at the same time yeah but at the
same time you don't need to date
everyone right woman I'm like you know
do you do you need to date every do you
need to date billions of men right does
a man need to date billions and billions
of women it's like no you don't so I
think if regardless of whether you're a
man or a woman I think if you do like
really have your stuff together and
you've got a right mindset and you work
on yourself truly and you B well I think
you can uh yeah you can you can change
the odds very heavily in your favor and
create your own reality yeah I've been
I've been having these conversations um
with my co-host moff on um a podcast
series I put on the unpluged alfit uh
YouTube channel if you guys aren
subscribed please go there um and we've
been calling it ladies night we've done
it for a few months now like three four
months or so and really we wanted to
take a different approach to having
conversations with gals on you know
topics around life and romance and stuff
like that and it's been difficult
actually I thought um like you know I
asked my once on fresh and fit years ago
I said you know the gals you have at the
table is that an accurate representation
of what's in Miami or do you um like
handpick um you know for you know
salacious sort of like amplification you
know for the camera and he's like that's
that's pretty much what we got so okay
and then I saw a lot of them getting
thrown off the show and a lot of veins
popping and yelling and stuff like that
I thought okay so let's so let's have a
conversation here and you know see if we
can do a little bit differently see if
we can you know see if we can go
somewhere and it's like it hasn't
changed that much you know it seems like
there's two distinct categories of women
that you know we'll have on the show and
it's like there's the ones that are just
a complete train wreck and but they hold
that to the public via social media and
um The Virtue signaling that
everything's perfect and they're a great
person and there's nothing wrong and
they don't have any beliefs to update
and uh you know that's not victim
mindset is something else and then you
have the other you know category which
seem just seems to be the women that
have it squared away right that are that
are in a good productive relationship
that see themselves as compliments you
know to one another and they work
together and like it's weird but it's
like there doesn't seem to be anything
you know where the single gals are
dealing with the situations like the
ones that are claimed right and I
haven't seen it improve yet it just you
know a lot of people have noticed in the
um you know in the shows and I throw it
in the comments of like what train wreck
you know like this that and the other
thing you know why isn't she she see
like this reality of you know the stuff
that she's talking about and I try to be
decent about it like I don't ever want
to throw anybody off the show like I've
been called names by some of these
chicks you know from time to time and
it's like no we're just going to keep
rolling you know that's your opinion
cool thank you so much and you know the
point that I'm trying to get at here is
that I haven't seen anything changed
people often ask me when I do podcast
you know because I've read my book and
they want to pull me on you know I'll be
like you know the question is well how
do you fix that like how do you improve
that like how do you like have the Sexes
benefit from one another to come
together rather than get pushed apart
sort of thing and I don't have an answer
to that because it requires a lot of
reflection and and self-ownership and I
think the people that get it get it and
the ones that don't just don't get it
and I don't think that you're ever going
to change the ones that don't get it
because they've they've been drunk on
the Kool-Aid for decades now of you know
the you know the lyrics and the notion
of um you know men ain't [__] and you
know women ain't [__] and uh you know
women are all hoes and men are all dogs
and you know you go back and forth and
it's like they're lobbing the ball back
and forth and nothing's really being
dealt with do you see anything you know
on the horizon where this is improving
or is it just like constant bickering
and fighting because I get a lot of that
mostly yeah I I do and maybe this is me
being uh the eternal optimist yeah I
think that we are I've I've said this
many times I think I think we're in a
really truly unique place in society
right now with the convergence of where
we are in terms of social aspects
cultural aspects religious aspects
technological aspects financial and
economic things like the the convergence
of all these things has never happened
before we've never been in a world
before where we have YouTube and
podcasts and uh Instagram and Facebook
and you've got this
weird uh hookup culture and you've got a
decline of religious devotion going on
and you have all of these people maybe
50% of people in the USA around my age
maybe came from a broken family and all
all of these things happening meanwhile
it's it's much harder to buy a property
than it used to be so therefore it's
harder to you know it's more expensive
to bring children into the world than it
used to be we have like this convergence
of all these factors on top of each
other and we've just never dealt with
this before as a species so I think
what's happening right now is the sort
of breaking eggs
part I think that there's a lot of
realization and a lot of Awakening going
on right and I think that um some of
that some of that looks a little bit
ugly and there can be a lot of fighting
and bickering and back and forth I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin Down Below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out